Prof: At the end last
time we saw this intemperate
quote from Hermann Kolbe on the
young van't Hoff:
"The fancy trifles in
it" (his book about the
arrangement of atoms in space)
"are totally devoid of any
factual reality."
The reason he thought so,
Kolbe, was he knew there could
be no way of knowing about the
arrangement of atoms in space;
they were just too small.
But he was wrong.
There was plenty of factual
reality.
What van't Hoff had done was to
collect information about
isomerism;
in particular about optically
active compounds,
those that rotated the plane of
polarized light,
or twisted it.
In looking at the Wiki,
I noticed some people talk
about "bending"
it.
Bending would be like this.
Right?
That's not what happens to the
plane of light as it goes.
It goes and it twists.
Right? It rotates;
it doesn't bend.
Bending is refractive index;
you know, light goes into the
surface of water and then bends.
But this is twisting the
direction that the electric
vector oscillates.
Okay, so these optically active
compounds that would do that,
when in solution,
were numerous,
and van't Hoff was able to cite
a number of examples;
for example, lactic acid.
But you remember who discovered
lactic acid?
Scheele already -- close to 100
years before this,
Scheele had isolated it from
sour milk.
But Liebig then found the same
analysis of the acid he got from
meat… isolated it from
meat.
And Wislicenus,
at this same time that van't
Hoff is working --
in fact, the guy who had one of
his helpers translate the work
of van't Hoff into German for
that publication and was
therefore castigated by Kolbe --
Wislicenus showed that these
things had the same
connectivity,
by chemical transformation;
these two acids,
the one from milk and the one
from meat.
Right?
If you look forty years later,
in the Encyclopedia Britannica
-- so this is a long time
afterwards, right?
-- about lactic acid,
it says it's hydroxypropionic
acid.
"Two lactic acids are
known, differing from each other
in the position occupied by the
hydroxyl group in the molecule;
they are known respectively as
α-hydroxypropionic
acid."
You remember what
α means?
It means on the carbon adjacent
to a carbonyl group.
Okay, so there's
α-hydroxypropionic
acid, which came from
fermentation and is called
inactive lactic acid.
Why would they call it inactive;
in what sense inactive?
Can you think what active
versus inactive would mean?
It means whether it's able to
rotate, to twist the plane of
polarized light;
whether it's optically active.
Okay, inactive lactic acid --
and they give the formula,
with an OH on the carbon next
to the carbonyl of the acid
group --
and 3-hydroxypropionic acid,
or hydracrylic acid,
which has the OH on the
terminal carbon.
Okay?
Now these are clearly
constitutional isomers.
It's a different sequence of
bonds.
Okay?
But they go on to say,
"Although on structural
grounds there should be only two
hydroxypropionic acids"
(these two) "as a matter
of fact four lactic acids are
known.
The third isomer"
(in addition to the inactive
one and the one that has the OH
on the last carbon) "the
third is sarcolactic acid."
Sarco means from flesh.
Okay, so that's the one that
Liebig found in meat extract.
In fact, Liebig was so
interested in meat extract that
he patented bouillon cubes,
and they were known for a long
time as Liebig's material or
whatever,
I forget exactly.
But I once looked at a train
menu from the late 19th century,
in the restaurant car of the
train, and they were serving
Liebig's extract.
Okay?
So there's the third one is
Liebig's,
the sarcolactic acid,
"and may be prepared by
the action of Penicillium
glaucum on the solution of
ordinary ammonium lactate.
It is identical with
α-hydroxypropionic
acid in almost every respect,
except with regard to its
physical properties."
That's sort of an interesting
statement, isn't it?
That it's identical in every
respect, except it's all
different.
Right?
What was similar about it,
do you think?
In what way was it identical,
if it had all -- its boiling
point, everything was different;
melting point,
crystal form,
everything was different,
all the physical properties.
But how could they possibly say
"it is identical in almost
every respect"?
Kevin?
Student:  Its formula.
Prof: What about its
formula?
Obviously they're isomers.
So they have the same
composition.
Prof: But the
constitution is the same,
the sequence of bonds.
Right?
"The fourth isomer,
formed by the action of
Bacillus laevolacti on
cane sugar resembles sarcolactic
acid in every respect,
except in its action on
polarized light."
So one rotated it to the right,
the other rotated it to the
left, and in every other respect
they were identical.
So there were four -- [and of
all right, left and inactive.
Okay?
But here, forty years after,
they don't give any explanation
of why that should be so.
Okay, tartaric acid we've seen
a lot.
Right?
Scheele; Berzelius coined the
name isomer to talk about
it;
Pasteur; Wislicenus again
showed the constitution;
which meant nothing to Pasteur.
Why would the constitution mean
nothing to Pasteur,
the nature and sequence of
bonds?
Yeah?
Student:  He believed
the positions in space mattered,
rather than the sequence of
bonds.
Prof: Would Pasteur have
written,
at the time he did this work,
"we don't know anything
about the position of
bonds"?
I don't think he would've
written that.
You know why?
Bonds wouldn't be invented for
another ten years.
There was no such thing as
bonds, when Pasteur did his work
in 1848.
Bonds came in 1858.
Right?
So Pasteur didn't have the
tools to think about this.
Okay?
So aspartic acid was an example
of something that was optically
active.
Amyl alcohol could rotate light.
Glucose could rotate light.
Notice that this didn't mean
they had both the one that could
rotate one way and the one that
could rotate the other way.
They had something that could
rotate light.
In the case of lactic acid they
had things that would rotate
either way.
Right?
In the case of tartaric acid,
after Pasteur,
they had that.
Okay?
And also laevulose and lactose
were another two that were known
but were not cited by van't
Hoff.
Malic acid -- you know what
that comes from?
Where's the root, mal?
It's apples, right?
So it's sour apples.
Okay, and most of the
derivatives of these compounds,
most things you could get by
chemical transformations from
these compounds were optically
active,
but not the stuff you got by
dehydrating malic acid.
If you got the double bond,
so you got maleic and fumaric
acid, two isomers,
but they didn't -- neither of
them rotated light,
neither right or left.
Right?
So that was destroyed in this
case.
And also there was another
example, which was replacing the
OH by a hydrogen.
So you have CH_2CH_2 in the
middle, instead of CH(OH)CH_2.
And that particular experiment,
van't Hoff was involved in;
he was involved in by
suggesting it to his fellow
student,
Bremer, who did it by treating
it with hydriodic acid and
phosphorous,
which was a way of removing OHs
and changing them to hydrogen,
in those days.
We'll see later that that's
called reduction.
But at any rate there were
these two derivatives of malic
acid that were not optically
active, although most
derivatives were.
Okay?
Now, van't Hoff,
as I said, was involved at
least in suggesting these
experiments.
And, as we said,
those two were inactive.
In van't Hoff's obituary,
a former student of his,
Bancroft, who was by this time
a professor at Cornell,
wrote: "In his whole life
he never made what would be
called a very accurate
measurement,
and he never cared to.
I remember his saying to me
eighteen years ago,
'How fortunate it is there are
other people who will do that
sort of work for us.'"
Right?
So it's great to do
experiments, but in some sense
it's even greater if you can
talk somebody else,
who's competent,
into doing them for you.
Okay?
And that was van't Hoff's
approach.
Now, what van't Hoff noticed
was that these compounds,
that were optically active,
all had something in common.
They all had these red atoms in
common.
What's special about the
carbons that are red,
that exist in the ones that are
optically active,
but don't exist in the ones
that are not optically active?
What's special about the ones
that are in italics in red?
What makes them different?
This is what van't Hoff noticed.
Chris?
Student:  Are they
chiral carbons?
Prof: Well they are,
but what did van't Hoff notice?
Chiral didn't exist then,
as a name.
Yeah Andrew?
Student:  They have four
bonds >.
Prof: They all have --
they use their four bonds to
bond to different groups.
No two things are the same.
Down here, this carbon that was
red here, has two hydrogens on
it.
Here it has two bonds to
another carbon.
Right?
But in the other cases they're
all, these red carbons are
unique in bonding to four
different things.
This one, for example,
this carbon is bonded to
hydrogen,
to OH, to another carbon that
goes out on this chain,
and another carbon that goes
out on that chain.
And those two chains are
different.
This one has a carbonyl group;
that has an OH.
So the difference can be quite
remote.
But they're different.
Okay, so that's what he noticed.
And we now call these chiral
carbons;
or stereogenic,
because they give rise to
special stereo arrangement in
space.
So what he said was,
"Every carbon compound
which in solution can rotate the
plane of polarized light
contains one or more asymmetric
carbon atoms."
That's what he called these,
that had four different things.
And he made models of carbon.
This particular set he folded
up, colored, pasted together,
and gave to this friend,
Bremer, who had done the
experiment.
And they're in the Museum
Boerhaave in Leiden now.
Now look at these things and
see if you can figure out what
some of them are.
Here are tetrahedra,
whose faces are colored.
So you could make…
if you had four different
colors,
that would denote being
associated with four different
things,
and each face would correspond
to a substituent.
Okay?
This one has colored vertices.
So instead -- you could use a
tetrahedron either way.
You could use the faces to
denote a neighbor,
or you could use the points to
denote where a bond is to the
neighbor.
And he did it both ways.
What are these here?
What are those models?
Those aren't tetrahedra.
Can you see why he might have
made those models?
Kevin, what do you say?
Student:  To show
pentavalence?.
Prof: No.
We talked about van't Hoff last
time, last lecture.
Do you remember what he was
talking about?
Lucas?
Prof: Ladenburg Benzene.
A triangular prism.
That's what these are.
And you remember this is 1,2;
3,5; 4,6;
or whatever it is,
that are this way.
If you color these two it's not
superimposable on one where you
color this one and this one.
Or this case.
That was AB or AB the other way.
Those he said were absolutely
different.
So those are models he made
with regard to this argument
with Ladenburg.
Okay, now here are his models
of these two things you get by
removing water -- pardon me --
from tartaric acid.
So what he has is tetrahedra
for the carbons.
And what does he mean when he
puts their edges together,
like this?
What's he using to denote a
bond?
There we go.
What's denoting a bond?
A shared vertex.
Right?
So here's a single bond, right?
What's this?
A double bond.
That's like what Lewis did
later -- remember when he
brought cubes together to share
an edge -- or a little bit like
that at least.
But now when you do that,
when you share an edge,
of the other two things on each
carbon, they're different;
this one red and not red.
Right?
You could put them together
this way, but you could also put
them together this way.
And you can't get from one to
the other without pulling them
apart and putting them back
together again.
Right?
So that would explain why
they're two different isomers;
maleic acid and fumaric acid.
Right?
That you get -- when you start
with tartaric acid and pull off
the water.
Or start with malic acid.
I was saying tartaric.
You start with malic acid,
pull off water,
and you get either this or
this.
Okay, so he could explain that
with his tetrahedral models.
The red denotes a red vertex,
obviously.
Okay?
Or if you have a single bond
you could count isomers.
Now what he says here is you
don't get all that many isomers
because it can freely rotate
about the bond between the two.
So the carbon atom is in the
center of a tetrahedron,
and its substituents are on the
vertices.
Right?
So the top carbon has three
things, R1, R2,
R3.
And what he shows here is you
can rotate that freely.
You don't count all these as
separate isomers.
Who would've thought you did
count them as separate isomers?
You may not remember the name.
Where was he?
What?
Student:  The guy from
>.
Prof: The guy from
Palermo.
Right?
Paternó
was his name,
right?
He tried to explain the
existence of isomers.
But van't Hoff says no,
that's not true;
you can freely rotate,
so you can't count that.
But you could have -- if you
looked down on R1,
R2, R3, you could look down and
see them clockwise,
from one to two to three,
or you could see them
counterclockwise from one to two
to three.
And you can't go back and forth
between those by rotating,
because they're in a certain
order.
So you do get isomers.
So he made this diagram to show
that free rotation about the
central bond results in rapid
inter-conversion,
and thus inseparability and
irrelevance of the isomers that
Paternó
talked about.
And they can be arranged
clockwise or counterclockwise,
which is not affected by the
rotation about the central bond.
And you can then count how many
isomers there are,
depending on whether R1,
R2, R3 are the same as four,
five, six, or are different
from four, five,
six.
Okay?
But maybe the most spectacular
thing he showed was that if you
put three tetrahedra together
like that,
you get these forms,
which -- what's the
relationship between these two?
Can you superimpose them and
have them be exactly the same?
Is there any relationship
between them?
Obviously if you just slid them
together,
R1 would be on top of R1 and
two on two,
but four and three -- this is a
four here,
it looks like a one -- four and
three would not be on top of one
another when you slid them
together.
And there's no way of twisting
it so it'll be right.
Right?
But there's a special
relationship between those.
They're not completely
unrelated.
What symmetry relates them?
Do you see?
Zack?
Student:  Right handed
and left handed?
Prof: Yeah,
they're mirror images,
like right-handed and
left-handed.
Okay?
So he predicted that if you had
two double bonds in a row,
with a common carbon in the
middle,
then you could get right and
left-handed,
where you can't get it with
just a double bond,
as in the maleic and fumaric
acid.
Those aren't
"chiral",
as we now say.
But this wasn't shown until
1935.
That's probably the longest
that there's been a correct
theory proposed,
until the time that it was
confirmed.
Or at least I don't know of
anything longer than that;
sixty-one years after he
predicted it,
before it was demonstrated to
be true.
And it was proved,
you see, in the labs of
E.P. Kohler,
the same guy we talked about
last time.
And here's the molecule he
used, down on the bottom left.
And we can enlarge it here.
So there it is.
Now, that molecule,
as you look at it,
would be superimposable on its
mirror image.
It looks planar.
Right?
Now let's think about that.
The bonds at that carbon should
be tetrahedral.
So one bond should be coming in
and out, or one pair of bonds,
and the other pair of bonds
should lie in the plane.
But if that's true,
then the one on the right would
have its four bonds coplanar --
right?
-- all in the plane of the
paper.
So there's something wrong here.
And you can see what's wrong if
you think about the p
orbitals that go into making a
double bond.
Right?
What's wrong with that
arrangement?
Why don't the p orbitals
like it?
Student:  They're
orthogonal.
Prof: They're
They don't overlap,
right?
What you need to do is to twist
it, like that,
so that the groups,
C_10H_7_ and C_6H_5,
come in and out of the plane.
Right?
And that's what then makes it
not superimposable on its mirror
image.
Okay, now if you wanted to
convert one mirror image to the
other --
notice if you used the plane,
something parallel to the
screen,
as a mirror,
what comes out in front of the
mirror would be the same on the
left.
But on the right C_10H_7 would
be back in, and C_6H_5 would be
coming out.
Right?
So if you want to interconvert
these, you have to put ten where
six is and six where ten is.
You have to rotate around the
bond.
But to do that you have to
break the bond,
because it's a double bond.
You'd have to go back to where
the p orbitals don't
overlap and you lose the double
bond,
and then you can keep rotating
and get the other mirror image
isomer.
Right?
But you have to break a bond to
do that.
So that's very tough.
Okay, now we were counting
isomers in homework for today.
And this slide goes through and
counts them.
I'm just going to begin it,
and then hustle through the
end, rather than go through it
in great detail,
because you've already worked
on it.
But this can be thought of as
an answer key.
Okay, so we want to count how
many different mono-substituent
positions there are in that
compound.
There's one.
Okay?
There's obviously a different
one, two.
Now about three,
is that different,
if you have just a
mono-substitution.
Is the blue different from the
red?
No, obviously because this
thing has rotational symmetry,
you could rotate it;
put the red on top of the blue.
So the blue's not a new one;
forget blue.
Okay, now how about that blue
one, is that a new one?
No, because the one in the left
front would go,
on that same rotation,
go the right rear.
So that one doesn't count.
How about that one?
Is that different or the same?
Can you rotate it so the one on
the front left becomes the one
on the front right?
No.
So now we have a question.
Is that something real about
the models?
Or is that just like the
sausages, that Kekulé
used, that it suggests a
difference, when there's not a
real difference?
Okay?
So, we'll put a question mark
on that one.
Okay, so there are two isomers,
if we don't count the two on
the bottom, and there's an
additional isomer if we do count
it.
Okay?
So there are either two
isomers, or conceivably three
isomers, of that one.
Okay, and notice that this one,
the third one in,
has exactly the same
arrangement among the hydrogens
as the first one.
So the numbers would be the
same: two and an additional one,
if you count those extras.
Now here, you have obviously
three different positions you
can have for mono -- top,
middle, bottom.
But also the ones on the right
are not superimposable on the
ones on the left,
if this is three-dimensional.
So you could have another
three, if they count.
And so on.
I'll not go through these --
notice -- except to note in this
one that there's obviously top
here and these three.
Now the question is,
are those three different or
not?
And we're following van't Hoff
here and saying it rotates
rapidly around here.
So on time-average you won't be
able to put those in separate
bottles, right?
They're going to interconvert
too rapidly to count.
So there'll be three.
But the two on the top are not
really -- they're not
superimposable by rotation,
in the model.
Okay?
So the question is whether you
have that additional one.
And in prismane there's only
one.
And then if you go
disubstituted,
if we start on the left,
if you start with one on the
top here, you can have the
second one here,
or here, or here.
That's clearly three.
But there might -- this one is
not superimposable.
That is, if you have this one
already, this one and this one,
as sites for the second,
are not superimposable.
Right?
So maybe we need another one
there and another one over here
as well.
So there might be an additional
two.
And again, this is the same as
that one.
And you can go through this --
and presumably you have done.
But anyhow these are the
answers I got.
And if you found something
different, let me know.
Maybe you saw something I
didn't see.
Okay, so that's interesting.
Now mirror images.
Here's me with a mirror image.
Right?
Now this is a question.
Why does a mirror exchange
right and left,
but it doesn't exchange top and
bottom?
How does the mirror know which
way gravity points?
Or how about if I lay on my
side when I looked in the
mirror, would it still exchange
left and right and not top and
bottom?
I'm talking about plane
mirrors, not funhouse mirrors.
That's an interesting problem,
right?
But notice, it doesn't change
either, because top is on top
and right is on right.
It didn't change right and left.
It left right on right.
What did it change?
Why does the mirror image look
different from the real image,
if it doesn't change right and
left, and it doesn't change top
and bottom?
Student:  Front.
Prof: It changes front
to back, or in and out.
Right?
Because my original self,
you see the back of my head,
and in the mirror image you see
the front of me.
So what a mirror changes is in
and out, not right and left.
Okay?
But our intuition interprets
that as rotation.
Because if I look like this,
and I go like this,
you expect it to change,
the right hand,
because you're accustomed to
people rotating.
You're not expecting me to go
pfff, like that and turn inside
out.
Right?
>
Okay, so people don't invert.
So our mind makes us think that
the person we see in the mirror
has turned 180°,
so that the right should be on
the left.
Okay?
And, of course,
this is not a new observation.
Through the
Looking-Glass -- you know,
Lewis Carroll,
and Alice going through.
And here are successive
pictures in that book.
There she is looking into the
glass, and we turn the page,
and here she is coming out,
on the other side.
Now notice something about this.
That's her right arm.
Right?
And in the previous picture it
was also her right arm.
That's not the way the mirror
image should look.
It should've changed the way it
looks, when you go from back to
front.
Okay?
Now, Lewis Carroll was a smart
guy.
He taught mathematics at Oxford.
Right?
But of course he didn't draw
the picture.
The picture was drawn by John
Tenniel.
And it turned out that John
Tenniel was blind in one eye;
a fact I only discovered
yesterday, on Wikipedia.
>
So is that the reason that he's
unable to perceive depth,
and draws the wrong thing?
No, it's much more subtle than
that.
Notice that the name of the
book is Through the
Looking-Glass.
She moved through the
looking-glass and her right arm
stayed right.
But if she had been reflected
in the looking-glass,
if the title had been chosen to
be In the Looking Glass,
rather than Through the
Looking-Glass,
then when you looked at the
mirror image it would've been
the left arm.
That's sort of cute.
So Carroll is more subtle than
you might give him credit for;
or John Tenniel, or both.
Okay?
Or look even further in the
book.
This was, notice, 1872.
What was going on in chemistry
in 1872?
Wislicenus was studying these
isomers of lactic acid,
the Scheele and the Liebig,
and showing that they had the
same constitution but were
different.
Okay?
So look what happens here when
she's talking to her kitty.
"Now, if you'll only
attend Kitty,
and not talk so much,
I'll tell you all my ideas
about Looking-glass
House…
Well then the books are
something like our books,
only the words go the wrong way.
I know that because I've held
up one of our books to the
glass,
and then they hold up the one
in the other room…
How would you like to live in a
Looking-Glass House,
Kitty?
I wonder if they'd give you
milk, there?
Perhaps Looking-glass milk
isn't good to drink."
Because in the college Carroll
knew Vernon Harcourt,
who was a chemist who was
involved in this work,
with Wislicenus.
So almost certainly they'd had
conversations about lactic acid,
the mirror image form.
Right?
So there's a lot of stuff in
Alice.
So was he referring maybe to
sarcolactic acid,
the one that comes from meat
instead of from sour milk?
Anyhow, chirality comes
from the Greek word
"χÑ”
iρ",
which means hand;
it's handedness.
So there's a right hand.
Now let's talk about…
and Lord Kelvin coined the
word.
He said, "I call any
geometric figure,
or group of points,
chiral, and say it has
chirality,
if its imagine in a plane
mirror, ideally
realized…"
(so don't take into account
moles or a fingernail that
hasn't been trimmed or something
like that) "…ideally
realized,
cannot be brought to coincide
with itself."
(By rotation and so on.)
Okay?
So let's consider x,
y, z coordinate
systems.
So there are points for every
point on the surface of the
hand.
And I could make an image of it
by changing some of the signs of
some of these things.
For example,
I could leave all the z
and y coordinates
identical,
but change the sign of
x, which would move
things from being on that side
to being on this side.
Got the idea?
Okay, so I'm going to make a
new hand, that looks like the
original one,
except every x
coordinate has changed its sign.
Change all the x
coordinates and we get that --
everyone see it?
-- ideally realized.
The shadow is a little
different and so on;
but ideally realized,
those are the ones that have
done that, right?
Changed one sign.
Now is one hand right and the
other hand left,
or are they both right?
Okay?
So what kind of relationship
would you say there is between
these?
Are they superimposable or are
they non-superimposable mirror
images?
Can you rotate and put one on
top, exactly to coincide with
the other?
No, because they're a right
hand and a left hand.
But that operation,
changing the sign of x,
corresponds to reflecting in a
mirror, which is yz,
in the yz plane.
Everybody got it?
Leaves y and z.
That's like leaving top,
top and right,
right, but changing in and out,
this way.
Okay? So that's a mirror.
Now, what would happen if we
changed all the y
coordinates -- can you see?
-- but left x and
z the same?
Then you'd get this.
Okay?
And what does that correspond
to?
Is that a rotation or a mirror?
Student:  It's a
rotation of your left hand.
Prof: So are they both
left hands?
This one, right?
And this is a right hand,
incidentally,
not a left hand.
Student:  That one and
that one are left hands.
Prof: And if I rotate
it, it would look like that,
right?
Is that the way it looks?
No, it looks like that.
Right?
So what was the operation that
did that?
Mathematically it's changing
the sign.
But how would you describe it,
in terms of mirrors and things
like that?
Student:  Horizontal
mirror.
Prof: It's a horizontal
mirror, that leaves right/left,
in/out the same,
but changes up/down,
top/bottom.
Okay, so that's reflection in
an xz mirror.
Now suppose we changed the sign
of all the z coordinates.
Can you guess what that's going
to do?
Prof: Not rotation.
Change the sign of z.
So that's going to give that
one.
Change in and out,
but leave right/left and back
-- change right/left and top --
pardon me.
Leave right/left,
leave top/bottom,
but change in/out.
That gives the one in front,
this one, right?
Okay, so that's reflection in
the xy mirror.
Now, there's some -- we've
occupied now four of the
octants.
But we can occupy the other
four as well.
For example,
we can change the sign of all
x and y,
but leave z the same.
Can you see what that's going
to do?
Change x,
change y,
but leave z the same.
There.
And what operation was that?
Was that a mirror?
Student:  Rotation.
Prof: Rotation about
what?
About z axis,
the one that didn't change.
Right?
How about if we -- that's
rotation around the z
axis.
How about if we change all the
x and z's,
but leave y the same?
What's that going to do?
That's easy,
once you know the previous one.
That's going to rotate about
the y axis.
Right?
And how about if we change the
sign of y and z,
and leave x the same?
Sophie do you see?
So we're going to change the
sign of y and change the
sign of z,
from the original one,
back here.
We're going to change y,
up and down,
and we're going to change --
z did I say?
-- yes, z,
in and out, from this one.
There's that one, right?
That changes in and out and it
changes up and down.
Right?
And what it is,
is rotation around the x
axis.
Now there's one octant that
hasn't been occupied yet;
the one that's out front,
top left.
Can you see how you get there?
What haven't we done yet?
Kate?
Student:  You have to
try and change all three.
Prof: If you change all
three, x and y and
z, then you come up there
and get the eighth one.
Okay?
Now what operation is that?
It's inversion through the
center of symmetry.
It's what I tried to do by
pffff, like that,
but I couldn't change myself
inside out.
Right?
So there's the center of
symmetry there.
And every point on the back has
one the same distance and along
the same vector,
to the front;
right there,
or to the base of my thumb.
Okay?
So here there are -- we looked
at three mirrors,
three rotations,
and an inversion.
Some of them changed right to
left, and some of them didn't.
Some of them were
superimposable.
Right?
Can you see,
in terms of changing signs,
what determines whether it's
going to be the same hand or the
other hand?
Angela?
Student:  If there's
been reflection then it would be
the other hand.
Prof: Reflection changes
hands.
So if you change x or
y or z.
Any other way to change hands?
Student:  Or you can
invert.
Prof: If you change
everything, x and
y and z.
So if you change an odd number,
then you change the hand.
Okay?
So chirality,
handedness, is
non-superimposable mirror
images, and it involves an odd
number of changes of
coordinates.
Now notice the right hand has
only one mirror image;
the right and the left are
mirror images of one another.
I can put the mirror image
here, or I can put it here,
or I can put it here.
Right?
So which mirror I use
determines where the new hand is
going to be.
But it's always the same mirror
image.
Okay?
Just generates it in different
locations and orientations.
Now, this is a special
property, handedness.
Right?
Or is it an everyday property.
We've looked at molecules.
Van't Hoff was able to come up
with what?
about less than a dozen
examples from all the molecules
that had been known up to that
time.
So what do you think?
Do you think most molecules are
chiral, or do you think most
organic molecules are not
chiral?
Well we had an exciting night
last night and learned about the
democratic process.
So the way to settle such a
question is to vote.
Okay, so how many -- we're
going to vote on how special is
chirality.
First, very special, right?
only unusual molecules will
have it.
Or, on the other hand…
like these carbons that have
four different things.
Or the alternative,
it's very general,
and what's unusual is ones that
are achiral, not like hands.
So here we go.
How many people think that
chirality is pretty special?
Okay.
It'll be a little like Indiana.
How many people think chirality
is not so special?
Ah, not very many.
That's what I anticipated.
It's pretty special.
The class voted overwhelmingly
>
there should be more achiral
than chiral molecules.
And the voice of the people is
the voice of God.
Right?
So let's look at words.
"You can use words,"
Alice said, holding up her book
to a mirror.
Okay, so here's a message:
LET'S DECODE AT NOON BUT
KEEP IT MUM. Okay?
Now let's make the -- change
the sign of x,
so we get the mirror image of
this.
Okay?
It looks like nonsense.
Is there anything special?
Students:  MUM.
Prof: MUM;
MUM is its own mirror
image.
Thus it's not handed,
it's achiral.
Right?
But it's the only word that has
-- that when you change the sign
of x it stays the same.
It's pretty special to be
achiral;
to be MUM,
at least, okay,
here.
Now any other words look
interesting?
Students:  NOON.
Prof: NOON looks
sort of interesting.
Is it superimposable on its
mirror image?
No.
So it's chiral,
handed, like most words.
You can have a right or a
left-handed NOON.
It does have symmetry though.
Watch what happens if we,
instead of using a mirror,
rotate the message on the
right.
So change both x and
y.
And now you notice what?
NOON is the same.
So it has symmetry.
It has rotational symmetry --
right?
-- but not mirror -- okay?
-- in two-dimensions.
So it has rotational symmetry,
but that doesn't keep from
being chiral.
Like a propeller is chiral;
it has rotational symmetry.
Okay, now let's mirror by
changing the sign of y.
Anything special here?
What?
Student:  DECODE.
Prof: DECODE is
the same.
So DECODE is a meso-word.
Right? It's achiral.
But it's harder to recognize
because we're not accustomed to
dealing with mirrors that are
horizontal.
We're much more familiar with
mirrors that are vertical.
So it's much easier to see it
in MUM than to see it in
DECODE.
So you can amaze your roommates
with that.
Okay, so how special is
chirality?
In the case of words it's not
at all special.
Right?
What's special is to be
achiral, to have some kind of
special symmetry.
Almost all words are chiral.
But there are certain achiral,
or meso-words,
such as MUM and
DECODE.
But they're very rare.
Okay?
It's the same with molecules.
Almost all molecules are chiral.
But if you work with very,
very simple ones,
as you do when you begin to do
chemistry, then a lot of them
are achiral.
But it's a very atypical
example.
Essentially every molecule in
you is chiral.
All your amino acids,
all the sugars,
everything;
almost everything.
Fatty acids aren't chiral,
but when they're parts of fats
they are chiral.
Okay?
But when we deal with very
simple molecules,
we often encounter achiral or
meso ones.
Now, we're going to go beyond
constitution into
stereochemistry.
So we've talked about
composition.
We've talked about
constitution,
the nature and sequence of
bonds.
And now we're going to go into
configuration and conformation,
the other two Cs.
These last three Cs all have to
do with isomers,
but there's a difference in
that the last two have to do
with arrangement in space;
what the traditional chemists
warned the young folks not to
think about,
in the third-quarter and the
early fourth-quarter of the 19th
century,
and what the Encyclopedia
Britannica still didn't know
about by 1911.
Okay?
But what's the difference
between configuration and
confirmation?
The distinction is based on the
model we make.
Right?
And because configurational
isomers relate to one another by
breaking a bond.
You have to break a bond to go
from one to the other and
reassemble the pieces.
Right?
But when you're talking about
conformation,
you can do it by rotating from
one to the other.
So Paternó
was talking about isomers that
related by rotation.
His particular ones rotate so
easily that it's very hard to
see different isomers,
in his case.
Right?
Although you can get
information about that kind of
thing.
Right?
But the ones that require
breaking a bond,
to go from one to the other,
those are much easier to deal
with.
Right?
And so we have different names
for them.
But it relates only to the
model we use,
talking about bonds,
whether you break them or not.
And you won't be surprised to
hear that there are some bonds
that are so easy to break that
it's easier to convert those
configurational isomers than it
is to convert certain
conformational isomers;
where formally all you have to
do is rotate about a bond,
but in the process other things
run into one another and make it
very difficult.
So configuration and
conformation relates to the
models we draw of the molecules,
not to something the molecule
itself fundamentally knows
about.
So that one's hard to get back
and forth, and that one's easy,
typically;
but it doesn't have to be that
way.
Okay?
So all isomers represent local
energy minima;
that is, if you were at a low
enough temperature,
the molecule could sit in that
structure and just vibrate;
have a zero-point amplitude of
vibration around that particular
structure.
But then you can get from one
to another.
You don't take every possible
structure, as Paternó
tried to do,
and say that all these
structures are isomers.
Because then there'd be an
infinite number and they
wouldn't last any time,
because they're always
vibrating.
But you can vibrate within a
little well here,
or a little well here,
or a little well here.
And those are different
isomers, not just different
phases of vibration.
Now, the words of
stereochemistry often involve
relationships.
For example,
two molecules that have exactly
the same constitution,
nature and sequence of bonds,
can be identical.
Okay? They're superimposable.
And if you wanted a name for
that you would call them
homomers.
But no one needs to use that
because it's always the same
thing.
So that word doesn't really
exist.
But if they're just completely
different, then you call them
diastereomers,
which has the same root as
diameter;
things that are as far apart as
you can get, right?
They're just plain different.
Those are diastereomers.
But they have the same
constitution,
the same nature and sequence of
bonds, but they're just
completely different in their
arrangement in space.
Or there can be a very special
relation in space.
You know what that is?
Students:  Mirror image.
Prof: They could be
mirror images,
which are not the same thing,
but they're going to be very
similar, in many respects.
Right?
So that one has a special name.
Diastereomer just means
different.
But enantiomer means mirror
image.
Right?
Okay, so these are
relationships between two
molecules.
You say this molecule is the
enantiomer of this molecule.
Okay?
Now we need to talk about
things like this,
as Lavoisier told us.
We need to think about the
facts, the ideas,
and the words.
And when we come to words,
now we need to convey such
complicated ideas,
we need pictures,
not just written letters.
Okay, so we need pictures for
our notation that will show this
third dimension.
Now, there are a number of
tricks that you can use to do
that.
Can you see what's being used
here,
in this particular picture of
-- which is an old-fashioned
picture when laptop computers
were new and they had very
simple programs.
Yeah.
Student:  Relative size.
Prof: I can't hear.
Prof: Relative size is
one, right.
The hydrogens that are far back
are small.
Anything else?
Any other clues that show the
three dimensions?
Yeah.
Student:  Slender lines
for bonds.
Prof: The lines for the
bonds.
They are thinner in the back
and notice that some of them are
wedges, showing that they are
coming in and out.
Anything else?
Corey?
Student:  Some things
are in the front and some in the
back.
Prof: How do you know
whether they are in the front or
the back?
Student:
>
Prof: Like this one
Prof: How do you know
it's in front of this one?
Student:  You can't see
part of it.
Prof: Because it hides
it, right?
That's a way you can tell.
There's another one,
which is if you look at this
one with the left eye and that
one with the right eye,
your brain is able to put it
together in three dimensions.
It will be hard for you to do.
I don't expect you to;
you usually use glasses to do
that, ok.
But you can see that they are
different.
Look at this hydrogen here.
There you see the bond and
there it's being a little bit
obscured, right?
So, there are different images
that your left and right eye see
which is why Tenniel might have
had trouble with the third
dimension.
Now, there's another way,
which is motion.
So, here's a complicated
picture, right?
It's hard to tell what's in and
out.
But if I grab it,
and do this,
then you can perceive what's in
and what's out,
right?
So, if you have a picture that
moves, which didn't used to be
possible, of course,
until you had computers that
can do this kind of thing.
So, that's another way –
motion.
There's that same molecule.
There're other ways.
What's new in this one?
Shadows.
Or here.
More obscuring and shadowing of
the balls.
Or here, even better,
right, depending on what you
want to show.
So, there are lots of
conventions or tricks that are
used to convey the third
dimension.
Ok, and next time we'll go on
to simple notation that you can
write on an exam,
like showing tetrahedral
carbons.